Gary we'll start with you Kelsey back
together what is what happened what is
going on with you guys right now what
can we expect to see in terms of that
relationship um so I mean with that this
whole next season that's coming out it
is definitely a rollercoaster for sure
there's a lot of ups a lot of downs
there's a lot of new temptations that
come into play that weren't there before
especially for me personally so yeah
it's a very interesting thing to see
with me and her this year I mean it
seems like each season there always is
something between me and Kelsey but I
must say this season is probably like at
the tippy top of the mountain for what's
gonna happen so Chloe what is that
reaction on your face right now I just
want to say something I can't but I know
I just know what he's talking about and
I think a lot of people are gonna be
surprised by Garrett's actions and not
Kelsey's yeah David giler actions Oh
Garrett stop it because you said there's
a lot of temptations especially for you
so is there jealousy and the
relationship is there cheating and the
relationship that we see well yeah what
kind of hurdles I mean there's a few
different hurdles I want people to find
out themselves but uh definitely I guess
there's like mutual jealousy and things
that happen between me and Kelsey with
other people and whatnot so let's all
say this I normally am like Kelsey's
like I don't think Kelsey's right most
of the time Kelsey is right a lot of the
time this season
then then Garrett is there anything that
you're worried for us to see play out
anything you want to clear up right now
no not really honestly I mean I guess it
is but it is okay are you guys at least
okay right
whether you're together still or not all
right is yeah yeah I mean Kelsey very
cool
we're always you know kind of come back
full circle we're always usually friends
at the end of whatever happens it's
never too bad
Kelsey didn't know any of us she always
knew Garrett first and they dated for a
long period of time before she started
working with me
so like whether they're together they're
not together like they have a special
bond when it comes to this crazy Cs
geeky family and I think that's always
gonna show through you know the fans are
always rooting for you
so hopefully the recap isn't a real
breakout time to think yes things happen
and like pass gets kind of brought up
and stuff I mean as you guys all know it
was a pretty rocky past with me and her
with all the other things that happen so
it's just kind of its kind of like
overcoming those and getting past that I
think all of us were kids and you're
seeing that's this season trance like
turn into more adults and take
responsibility for the things we've done
and I think all of us or I'll speak for
myself I know I'm over being a kid and
I'm know Garrett feels that way yeah I
think a lot on a lot of cast members
Chloe you always seem to know everything
about everything that is happening I
think you are like the son of siesta key
and you just know all the things but I
was going through your Instagram and you
have a long-term boyfriend in real life
but he's not on the show yes why is that
um so we in April it was our three-year
anniversary and he just does not want to
be a part of this everyone knows him
very well but I can say that there's
been a lot in my life that has changed
the last month and I may or may not be
single and I hope that that we may get
to see that in season four it's funny
because I always thought
were single because you don't make about
him that much and does the other cast
members of this show ever feel like well
we have to put all of our lives on the
show so walking you have to put your
whole life on the show yes yes I got all
the time that it's unfair and I agree
with them but I also can't control
someone to do something that they don't
want to do if it was up to me he would
have been on the show the whole time
okay but now it looks like maybe you are
possibly single so will we get to see
the aftermath of what of what has
happened this season
hey if people tuned in and you get a
season four I am so ready to show my
love life and I hope that we get to do
that